welcome everybody welcome to a stereo
planning my name is Mark Cargill and
I'll be chairing the meeting almost at
this evening I'm just gonna take a pause
for a few moments so that the members
can have a look at the update sheet
because there's a number of items on the
update sheet there are copies around for
you to have a look at as well and I'll
just give you a few moments have a look
through them and then we'll stop the
proceedings
our members are happy and an opportunity
to read the update she
thank you right then all start the
proceedings for this evening right
welcome to this planning meeting as I
mentioned my name is Mark Cargill right
please note this is a planning meeting
with public participation a lot of
public meeting so only people registered
to speak will be allowed to do so during
the evening the procedures for this
evening are that we will have a
introduced an item with the officer then
there will be the town and parish
councils available to speak objectives
applicants and all supporters and then
or member members will be able to
question speakers at any opportunity at
any point after their presentation the
after that they go into technical
discussions which is technical questions
of the opposite and then debate and the
photo right this evening like I see
could you mind turning your phone's
either off or to decide when to please
and I think I'll just check mine as well
just in case okay now tip sort of
microphone I've just got a bit too close
myself it can if you get too close to
the microphone it gets distorted please
just back away from it and speak clearly
and you should be alright for the
evening there are no fire alarms
scheduled for this evening so if you do
hear one please
follow the officers out of the room and
meet in the car park opposite down the
side of the windmill pub okay I will now
like to ask the officers to introduce
themselves start with my right Caroline
Nash committee services Ross chambers
legal services good evening my name is
Dave Kenyon I'm the western team leader
in my role as an important advisor to
the committee I can clarify any planning
issues that may arise doing so I'm bound
by the code of Professional Conduct of
the Royal Town Planning Institute
planning committee members are not bound
by this
and case officers recommendation or by
any oral advice Anthony on planning
officer Charlotte dicks planning officer
James Hodgkins planning officer thank
you very much
I cannot start the meeting them
apologies for absence chairman apologies
receive from cats the carriage and from
councillor Richards thank you
disclosures or interest members I'd like
to start the ball rolling
I am the remember on item one and I'm
looking around to see if what the first
speaker is actually count Sir James Kim
James is here in the a chemist struggled
to get here I think from the from the
previous meeting
so I've said that I'm happy to read his
notes out in my patch as the item - I am
the ward member for there but I have no
knowledge of this application I come to
it with an open mind and I will be
sitting down on item eight so I won't be
speaking on that particular point
Thank You chair yeah item number 117
lieblick Oh 207 six outline I do know
the Apple
really Thank You castle answer I have
application three I should be speaking
at the ward member thank you very much
at the answer well as I mentioned I'm
now going to stand down and the counts
of Audrey will be taking over the
chairing for the first item
so good evening so we're gonna start
this evening with application number 17
Oh 207 six stroke out land off School
Road School Road sorted priors this is
the construction of up to sixty eight
dwellings a new village green new roads
foot waves community car park drainage
and highway improvement works to school
Road and a new noise attenuation Bund
all matters reserved except access so we
start off proceedings with the planning
officer and the young introducing the
item Thank You chair so here we have the
black spot indicating the location of
the site in proximity to the village and
Salford priors off to the south south
side of School Road the aerial
photograph with the citation in red
currently farmland this slide shows the
allocations in the now adopted
neighborhood development plan that's a
sulphate seven neighborhood development
plan and the site in question is as
large the large site here there as the
chair said it is an application in
outline in fact all matters are reserved
including access although we have had a
lot of information on access that it
will be subject to further scrutiny and
therefore that matter is also reserved
this is the this is the master plan
submitted so it's it simply shows how
the the scheme will devolve ship
planning permission be granted in phases
so we have the the pinkish color here
phase one residential zone one and then
moving on to the present shape of Zone
two and it gives you an idea of the
village green concept that the community
are keen to pursue the black snake sort
of line here is the noise attenuation
bond that emerged during the course of
considering the application we consulted
our environmental health officer
because there was an issue that have
been identified about potential noise
from the fruit packing business which
forms part of orchard farm along with
the potential vehicle noise of the
lorries arriving at that farm so what
came out of that discussion was a
proposal for an attenuation button which
the environmental health officer has
indicated is a critical aspect of the
development and without it he would
struggle to support the scheme so moving
on this is an illustrative plan which
gives members an idea of how the scheme
might develop again using the Crescent
concept we can simply see how that might
happen there is a network of public
footpaths in the verse in the vicinity
and as you can see there are a couple
that follow the boundary of the site
there was some concern raised by the
county footpads office is saying that
the bun potentially could conflict with
the width with the footpath along this
boundary but that will be subject to
further detail and accurate and plans as
to exactly where the Bund will be
located to avoid those sorts of issues
just remembers interest is part of the
scheme and part of the policy in the NDP
there's intended to be a permissive
right-of-way formed along this
northwestern boundary and that will come
through as part of the phasing of the
development just some photographs to
give members some context so we have
residential zone 2 here with the new
village green in front so it all happens
behind this boundary and the general
area an arrow here which points down to
where the development would be within
this large field and then looking the
other way up the road again residential
zone 2 is behind the hedge the hedges
proposed to be removed and I know that
that's something that we don't often
encourage but one of the key aspects of
this development is to
try and bind certain aspects of the
village more closely together physically
and by providing this central central
village green which by its very nature
ought to be seen and will provide that
physical function so the hedge is
proposed to be removed but in
compensation for that there will be
extensive new planting which should
really exceed what we are likely to lose
here from an attack a log ecological
point of view that's the just the green
arrow here shows the access point in
towards his farm which leads you on to
the packing Factory and the cooking the
cookery school and the farmhouse itself
further back down the road towards the
village looking back up the road we see
residential zone one again there's the
there's the access to the farm and so
residential zone one just sits in here
and just again just as some images of
the access road leading up to the
packing Factory and to the cookery
cookery school known as the alley the
recommendation is to approve with
several conditions there's also section
106 and it was also subject to the
update with a the additional amendment
to the development description which
incorporates the noise attenuation bond
which wasn't appearing before it is all
matters we served and that includes
access and there's additional
recommendation were requiring them and
as a standard condition really limiting
the number of houses to 68 dwellings
thank you chair thank you any questions
at this stage for many counselors no in
that case let's move on to our speakers
for this evening the first one if he's
here representing salted friars parish
council is councillor Kim James if he's
not here then
my counselor Cargill to speak on his
behalf you sure okay so counselor
Cargill will speak at the end of the
presentations in that case the next
speaker we have is councillor Peter
Morse
so I'd like to my Peter Moss to the
table that's fine always be a cancer in
my eyes Peter
just to clarify six minutes I understand
German thank you you presented today
with yet another application with a
market housing mix doesn't meet the
preferred mix laid down in the core
strategy on file is a 36 page report
from Litchfield explaining on behalf of
the applicant why the scheme deserves
retreated as yet another exception to
the core strategy on market housing mix
and the 28 page report from the
council's consultant looking at the
Litchfield justifications and I'll talk
about that in detail at a moment
chairman but I think at this point is
worth remembering that the core strategy
market housing mix approved by this
council in July 2016 was evidence-based
and approved by an independent planning
inspector the applicant is in effect
trying to explain what's different about
this site and how things have changed
over the last 18 months now you can see
from page 10 of the agenda chairman that
the variation from the core strategy mix
is significant and as usual the
applicant is asking for significantly
more four bedrooms and larger houses
than many fewer one and two bedroom
houses so I won't take you through the
36 and 28 page reports but it's worth
noting that on page 24 of our
consultants report the soulful prose
requirement over the next five years is
not that far removed from the core
strategy and very different into what's
being proposed here tonight clearly that
been negotiations with the applicant and
changes made to the application but even
then there were fewer one and
two-bedroom properties and our
consultants recommend significantly
fewer Chairman you'll be aware that
housing mix market housing mix has been
a concern of this council
sometime and as a result new proposals
are being put forward through a draft
development requirements supplementary
planning document in Section M 13.9 the
whole range of new tests are put forward
that applicants will be expected to have
researched as part of any justification
from moving away from the core strategy
mix of market housing I believe that
this council is entitled to take this
into account as emerging policy and if
you do so you will find that this
application fills the justification test
on at least five grounds firstly speed
of local sales shouldn't be taken into
account
there should be an up-to-date housing
NEET survey there should be an analysis
of regional factors there should be an
analysis of impact of other factors such
as help to buy and wider economics on
the housing market and there should be
evidence and analysis of trends in the
room size of dwellings and the impact of
home working Chairman I believe this
application does not meet our emerging
policies our market housing mix I hope
you will either reject the proposal or
it needs to fir it for further analysis
thank you thank you very much our
councillors have any questions for peat
moss councillor bonds just going to
write it just stays within the sole food
beverage plan that are not competent to
speak on other questions for peat moss
thank you very much
so I'd now like to invite to speak
Andrew Wilkins
I understand as the agent for this
development three minutes mr. Wilkins
good evening and thank you chair members
and officers it gives me great pleasure
to speak tonight in support of this
application pleasure
because numerous parties have worked
successfully and collaboratively to
deliver a unique vision
an application that is before you this
evening if perhaps I could start by
taking you a few years back the sulphate
prize neighborhood plan was in its
infancy from Stratford district and
indeed sulfus sulphate prize was under
siege with housing applications the
neighborhood plan group held one of its
first surveillance a beauty parade of
sites for consideration by the community
at this event I was proposing a on land
owned by my client but a member of the
community water Thompson came up to me
in a very polite but positive fashion
and explained that he felt our scheme
was a wasted opportunity elaborating
further water expressed the desire to
see the village that is currently
separated in two halves United through
post suburban design with the creation
of a [ __ ] to frame in a large village
screen he sketched this out as vignette
for me onto a napkin which sadly cannot
be presented tonight we reflected on
this and as a company we believe
strongly in working closely with local
stakeholders in sulphate priors we had
the special vision and a progressive
forward-thinking neighbor plan steering
group who are not intimidated by change
this was their opportunity to provide a
blueprint for surprise moving forwards
even if this meant the village would
take more housing than strictly required
by a lsv to settlement thankfully my
land owner Mycroft Perry is pretty
unique
well not that pretty but certainly
unique he wanted to see several things
coming from this development of course
as a commercial element but this was not
going to be the driving force most
importantly it was working with the
community creating a legacy and taking
pride in what we created this dictated
our strategy and is shown in the master
plan
so instead of following the herd and
banging in a smash-and-grab application
we help back waiting for the
neighborhood plan to involve and embrace
the vision and subsequently became the
cornerstone of the neighborhood plan
officers at first rather taken aback
with this proposal as it's just so
unique and has a design philosophy over
and above most applications up for
consideration but officers have worked
with us and supported us on the journey
of realizing the plans objectives so
here you have it
a high quality scheme that I believe is
unique to the district a locally
supported scheme that is dedicated to
uniting two hearts of this village and
something that we should all be proud of
I'd like to thank the community the
parish council the neighbourhood plan
group Walter Thompson and Malaya Croft
for giving us the opportunity of running
with it obviously what peat moss is very
eloquently set out about housing mix
what do you have to say about it
well I prepared a note which I'm going
to refer to because I had a hunch that
Nick's will be coming up we're aware of
obviously the policy CS 19 and it's a
district-wide assessment that needs to
be considered but there also needs to be
considered with the other adopted plan
the neighbourhood plan policy s pas
which obviously supports this
application so there are two policies
that need weighing up we're also aware
of a recent decision made by East
Committee for a Sian bishops which in
turn and refused on mixed grounds and
there are various differentiating
factors between that and this one
firstly we have an adopted neighbour
plan in place and this specifies a need
for family housing to support the
village school and amenities and the
neighbour plan also obviously supports
the present vision for this site we also
have support from that the Parish
Council who have very publicly come out
to support this application and in the
assessment that was referred to by
councillor Morse it wasn't highlighted
that it's been agreed between various
consulting the sulfur prize is different
to other settlements within its district
its existing housing stock is very
heavily orientated towards two and
three-bedroom houses coupled with that
the new houses proposed here and
recently developed by bovis at the Alamo
site means that sulfur prize as a
settlement has delivered in accordance
with CS 19 so sulfur prize has delivered
a mix in accordance with the policy
clearly with as an applicant we're
caught between a rock and a hard place
sis has spent three or four years
evolving this layout and we've got two
adopted development control policies
that need way not just want to give a
follow-up councillor job a when you say
between a rock and a hard place I mean
delivering an appropriate housing mix
isn't prevented you can still keep this
scheme and it's obviously I concede the
positive benefits of this scheme but you
can keep this scheme and still deliver
an appropriate core strategy compliant
housing mix we didn't that scheme we
could I don't dispute that but we would
in order to create the vision the
present and the neighborhood plan one we
would be looking at a scheme of
high-density housing which would
probably end up in order to create this
at about 120 units in order to do it we
couldn't create a present like this in a
vision with a policy compliant mix
unless we increase the numbers
significantly counselor Vance yes one of
the questions obviously cancer jaws the
other question is the sleepy re who are
saying should be refused because it's
over the numbers this gone under next
one now you're saying in the parish
well then they're delighted because I
mean it's in their neighborhood plan
that's adopted and gone through
referendum
it's what the community wants any other
questions for mr. Wilkins thank you very
much mr. Wilkinson so now if I can
invite councilor
Cargill who is the ward member but also
thank you chairman I first will read off
the notice from accounts of James I'm
not saying they're in a speech format
but anyway or even through the auto palm
application is a key policy of surprise
National Neighborhood Development Plan
and received a lot of positive support
locally with very few negative comments
as an outline application it delivers
the NDP's aims the comments he houses
this the proposed scheme is in
accordance with assault for seven
Neighborhood Development Plan policy sp8
as adopted by the District Council a
scheme that was developed over four
years of public consultation workshops
the local scheme has been conceived by
parishioners and not by developer or
local authority policy sp8 has been
scrutinized by the local authority
planning policy team stuff he council
tease the application delivers low
density housing the rural area 35%
affordable housing 13 custom build or
south built plots key design buildings
on the corners of development to act as
focal points public open space are
approximately three point six two
hectares road safety improvements for
the local school with traffic calming
measures community car parking political
residence and the village shop and post
office soft prizes a category two local
service village as defined in policy six
CS 16 and should deliver approximate 84
houses that figure has been superseded
by the Neighborhood Development Plan for
the purpose of achieving good quality
housing design on sites supported by the
public and to resist inappropriate
development within the village therefore
this application meets the sustained
the aims of the MPF particularly
paragraphs xlvii 255 which relate to
delivering a wide choice of high quality
homes the aim is to promote sustainable
development in rural areas located where
will enhance or maintain the vitality of
the rural community on the boundary of
this development is the primary school
village shop and post office the village
hall and the main bus route and that
also meets the criteria of the MPP F
it's a low density site with a higher
density of housing as as mentioned would
project prejudice the objectives of the
NDP plan together with a local design
objectives of policy sp8 one of its key
aims is currently the village is split
to do two halves and needs a focal point
and further development which will
physically link the two halves of the
village
if proposed public open space supersedes
the district councils requirement of the
developer therefore this application
developed in the public realm shows what
can be achieved when a community
involved from conception in a planning
application
likewise on highways matters with the
exception of meeting highways access
requirements there will be no other
requirement from the Highways Authority
however his application delivers more
school Road will be widened for a school
drop-off point traffic armed 8 speed
cushions a new bus stop and four
crossing points in conclusion given that
this out playing outline application
fully achieves the aims of the
neighbourhood plan in terms of the
safest from a vibrant community meeting
local economic environmental and society
socialist policies and is include
formative whether the core strategy and
meets the requirements of the MPP F the
instrument Road application has actually
been met with more negative comments
which is quite interesting right I'm
just going to do my little bit before I
finish my quilters part on both
applications and King James on behalf of
the council would like to press for a
condition that on each of the playing
applications coming forward now the
homes are fit for 20
first century and have digital
connectivity with fiber laid where fiber
optic has run through to all the
premises and he would like that as a
condition right now my sort of thoughts
on this is there's a lovely law out
there isn't that called the law of
unintended consequences
and I do wonder sometimes whether the
government when they came up the
Localism Act fully envisaged communities
like theirs taking halt or the planning
process and developing their own schemes
over and above what is actually
necessarily required of them within the
core strategy and the MPPs
they took a bold step into the world
community design with the developers as
well it's a modern scheme and it brings
cohesiveness to the village itself the
village had a vision of how they wished
the community to be in the future and
this is now enshrined in their own DP
there are course issues one loss of good
quality farming land which is a real
concern for me housing mix has been
discussed thoroughly I think thirty
seconds mark and the concerns over noise
must be addressed on the plus side
family affordable housing at the primary
school is short of numbers so that's the
potential plus as well finally as I
mentioned if Planning Commission is
granted then a request that connection
the fiber should be included thank you
thank you very much so any questions for
councillor Carville I have one if I make
just both as Ward member and if you can
for the for the parish council if for
whatever reason the mix was to be
altered so the the agent mentioned it
might double the number of homes was
that ever debated the parish councils to
whether they would still be in favor of
the development
I'm not aware of that but I do know that
the the views of feelings of the parish
council are quite strong on this game in
other words as it is okay thank you very
much no questions Thank You councillor
Cargill so now we have a session where
councillors can
technical questions of the planning
officer so again any technical questions
council jars notes in page ten of the
report under the housing mix excuse me
it says on outline schemes the market
housing mix is normally deferred to be
considered at the reserved matters stage
however the applicant would like the
percentage housing market mix to be
agreed at this stage and tied by
condition is there anything to stop this
committee from saying we agree with the
proposal that it will be Mac 68 but we
think it's more appropriate for the
housing mix to be determined at the
reserved matters stage because clearly
then if we've got a merging policy which
we've been referred to I would have
thought that's the more relevant time to
be looking at housing mix because you
are looking at it at the specifics of
the top this is a matter that was raised
with the applicant when the application
was submitted in outline they were
making a clear direction as to
establishing at this outline stage the
mix that they would like to pursue and
therefore officers felt duty-bound at
that point to challenge that because
kicking it down the road will be
confronted with the same arguments so
really the dialogue commenced from day
one and this is this is where we've
arrived I don't think it will help the
applicant at all if we try to insist
that the mix is reserved or conditioned
matters for whatever reason I don't know
what those reasons are but I've been
charged with the duty of addressing
their proposal and this is where we are
currently my question is is it open to
this committee to say we don't want my
housing mix to be tied at this stage
because we think that is more
appropriate to be assessed to reserve
matters and we do we have the ability to
approve that
vacation irrespective I think it I think
it is within your gift to to have that
amount of conditioned if you if you if
you considered that to be the
appropriate way forward because and the
other reason I ask that is because at
page six and seven the development and
enabling officer right I'm looking at
the comments and my understanding is he
says at the top of page seven he sees no
justification from any derogation from
the above mix is that in reference to
this issue of housing no this well that
that's in relation to the to the
affordable mix not the market mix and I
think the development in enabling
officer hood read sort of out outline
ideas as to what they might do about
affordable housing some of which the
officer couldn't live with and that I
think is entirely reasonable to be an
issue that can be addressed to the
reserved matters stage nope in either
way his remit doesn't extend out the the
policy officer from our policy officer
commented on on the mix and was
satisfied with the mix that we'd arrived
at following the specialist in port
and just so unclear it so is my
understanding that the justification for
the summary of the justification for
coming away from at is at page tan and
it's a three paragraph serpent it says
following discussion with policy team
officers are now comfortable with the
proposed mix based on previously
rehearsed factors namely the objective
of the NDP to provide more family
accommodation the 2011 census data and
the market housing mix achieved on on
the Alamo Station Road in other words
other areas in sulfur prize have an
appropriate housing mix yeah I mean I've
from if it's helpful for members I
compiled a table earlier on hopefully
you can see that can you not see that
and what I've done is I've I've
tabulated the Alamo site what was
achieved there I've then added the next
table which is this development and I've
also added that a table for the
application that follows this this this
one and then the final concluding table
shows what would be achieved overall and
as you can see for two beds well to be
no warm beds throughout the whole of all
the schemes have been no warm beds two
beds would be to represent 25% and they
CCS nineteen preferences between thirty
five and forty three beds is forty six
percent so that's just about just about
right just slightly over by one percent
and for Plus beds twenty nine percent
overall and the limit is twenty percent
so it's nine percent over but having to
having taken into account objected over
the NDP which is specifically saying
that they want to attract more families
to the village and for the other factors
that were taken into account by our by
the housing specialists both on their
side and on our side this in our mind
represented a reasonable compromise the
scheme first came at seventy percent for
plus bed on this particular scheme and
we managed to negotiate that negotiated
down to 43
% 4 plus bed and taking all things into
account we felt that that was a
reasonable compromise in this instance
for Salford try priors and with the fact
they have an adopted NDP and a local
locally driven scheme that they are
entirely content with on this
application and the next one are
opposing it although they're not
speaking because the village numbers are
over now do we take the core strategy
numbers or did we take the village plan
numbers because I don't know what the
village plan numbers are well the yeah I
mean the examiner for the NDP fully
acknowledged that it was taking it over
the the core strategy number for the
village but felt that they because it's
an NDP it's a local scheme the the
community of actively decided that they
want to take it over the core strategy
numbers for the benefit of their
community and he felt that even going
beyond the margin of the core strategy
still felt it was broadly in line with
with the with the strategy and was able
to support it as the examiner of the end
NDP it was the examiner of the
government examiner for the night and
for the Neighborhood Development alone
Thank You Chet I'm in fact counselor my
question is I just got one technique
whether it's probably for you Ross and
we've been asked a condition fiberoptic
provision for all of these houses are we
allowed to do that I'm just wondering
whether it might be unfair
to ask the developer to do something
that they might be reliant on a
third-party to achieve I think that's
actually one for the planning officers
yeah Thank You chair I think in this
instance it is a matter of providing the
the infrastructure if you like so it's
not entirely
it isn't dependent on a third party it's
providing the infrastructure so that
that can be plugged into a network so
it's it's something that is fairly
standard I think now in housing schemes
so your answers we could condition it
could condition it yeah so just before
we get to public debate if I could just
ask that's people up on this table to
think about were members to propose them
to potential conditions one about the
fiber and one about whether we was a
different exclude the housing condition
okay sleepless night so I now open it up
to debate amongst the members Thank You
chair I think it's a shame because this
application and the offices report is
almost completely dominated by the
effect of the sort of plyers
neighborhood plan I mean personally I
think the scheme as proposed is is fine
I think the concept of joining the the
two parts of the village together with
what looks a fantastic idea a great
piece of public open space I'm not quite
sure what's going to happen to the rear
of this development in future years but
but that's not part of this application
so perhaps we should ignore that I said
I'm disappointed the parish council
can't be here and that bad I've got lots
of questions that I didn't feel that I
could I could ask
the ward member are we truly
disappointed however on such a crucial
point CS 19 which is housing mix and
also in the S PD document m4 which again
reiterates the policy from CS 19 to
maintain the housing mix that we haven't
actually had the stratford district
council independent examiner here to ask
questions because I think it's so
fundamental that he should be here from
what I've heard and I haven't heard much
nothing that I've heard tonight would
lead me to believe that there is a sort
of exceptional circumstance where in
this instance we should agree to the
applicants wish to leave the housing mix
out of reserve matters so to start the
ball rolling chairman I am more than
happy to propose that we grant this
planning consent but subject to Clause 9
in the recommendations being a reserved
matter so this committee can look at it
again with if we need our independent or
independent adviser to find out why he
or she feels that we are going to vary
so wildly from what is an adopted core
strategy CS 19 thank you Jeff councillor
jars
yes I completely agree with them
councillor Norton it's it is such a
shame because what one wants to heap
praise on this scheme it's community led
it's in accordance with the
neighbourhood plan it makes good use of
open space you know it isn't it isn't a
dense scheme which seeks to cram
everything on though and so and I
understand what the applicant says which
is almost that that should justify those
positive elements should justify away
from move away from the housing mix but
I think that escapes the point that that
policy we should be able to have all of
those things
don't think this commission should be
put in a position which is saying oh
you've got a great scheme it's
community-led and leaves those of open
space but but the downside is you've got
it means you've got to severely
compromise on your approved policy in
relation to housing mix it seems to me
that there's a logical way around it and
I agree with counsel often is to say
well we do what we usually do which is
to say we approve the scheme in outline
but at this stage we don't make we don't
tie the issue of housing mix and I think
there are good reasons for saying that
because actually housing mix goes
hand-in-hand with a detailed layout and
reserve matters there's a reason those
two things are considered together and
it's because it actually does tie in
with what your actual layout and the
specifics are going to be so and I think
also if we have emerging policy it makes
much more sense to consider the housing
mixed question again when that policy is
potentially further down the line and
further updated and that can be properly
taken into consideration so they all the
reasons that I would I don't know if it
was a proposal from Council or sand yes
well I would second I would second a
proposal that sought to add in a
condition about for the fiber optic
optic Ron Wood has been said and takes
out condition 9 about the housing mix a
nice check from Council a lot are you
happy for that fiber optic condition to
be part of Jerry's long as it's possible
saki-chan
and in response to the proposal and the
second earth about deleting condition 9
if I can clarify one of the reasons in
this instance the officers made that
recommendation was having due regard to
local sentiment as mr. Young has
mentioned they actually wanted a higher
mix of larger dwellings and that has
been reduced to what is before you and
the condition was in some ways
reflecting those local opinions now
policy CS 19 is a one policy in the
course
today and I think is the aging mentioned
there are various policies and you have
to balance pros and cons and officers
were mindful that it was not a strict
adheres to CS 19 but bearing in mind
what the Neighborhood Development Plan
was saying what the parish council was
saying we felt it was appropriate to
apply that condition now to compare with
what the case officer has said in
response to the questions raised by a
councillor Giles yes it is certainly
within the remit of the committee if
you're mindful to grant outline
permission to to grant it without
condition 9 because when the reserved
matters application comes in if it still
has the same mix or a different you will
be able to consider that separately so I
can confirm that you would be able to
grant consent without condition 9 if
that is your wish likewise if I can just
on the fiber-optic I again would concur
that would be a legitimate condition if
you were minded to impose that condition
as well thank you Jeff
thank you very much that's one
clarification so we did in the update
sheet have a further condition proposed
sixty-eight dwellings so again to the
proposal and seconder would you want
that condition to be in or if now the
housing makes is something that we
debate as you course would you would you
well I would want that in because that's
the whole purpose of looking at this
specific proposal is that is the density
we're happy with the concept of the
density and the plan for that openness
and so personally I would definitely
want that today in I'd agree with
counselor Charles I don't think we're
here to discuss the housing numbers if
the scheme was so compromised by the
housing mix being in accordance with
this 19 it might be that a fresh
application would come in which which
would show a slightly different scheme
with with a different density okay thank
you
one more point in the plan officers are
artists
yeah Thank You chair in previous schemes
why we've dealt with outlined
applications it's been our normal
practice to include a condition not just
strike out the condition and leave it at
that but to actually have a positively
worded condition to say that as part of
the reserve matter scheme the developer
shall submit a mix you know which will
be agreed as part of the negotiation
rather than just leaving it not giving
clear steer that in fact that is what we
want yeah yes why not I take your point
yeah I think that that's fine if we're
all clear and perhaps yeah we could we
could word that if this committee is
minded - yeah so - except with the
conditions we've discussed with that if
I may as we have a proposer and second
4:17 stroke Oh - oh seven six outline
and the recommendation is to grant
subject to the prior satisfactory
completion of a section 106 planning
obligations to secure the Clio financial
contributions affordable housing and
on-site landscape management plan and
such the conditions that are set out on
page 16 with the addition of a new one
which is limiting the development to
sixty eight dwellings which was in the
update nodes a replacement of condition
nine to provide some guidance we have
proposed wording for that yeah are you
happy to take it as read there is a
standard condition we have here and also
that there will be a condition about
laying at least the infrastructure for
fiber to the purpose for the 21st
century I think was how was it winded
also whether the condition about the
Bund had been included as well so don't
think that appears on page 16 but it's
in our update treat the condition is
encapsulated by the headline there at 22
submission of a scheme of noise
mitigation
everything's captured under that yeah
okay so on that basis I'd like to ask
members
all those in favor of granting
permission so none against that is
granted thank you
his counselor car get around
okay thank you very much indeed sir I'll
just wait to to arrive the next item on
the agenda is 17 / 0 2 4 7 5 landed even
wrote saw the price again and Anthony is
our presenting officer Thank You chair
so once again in sulfur priors we have a
second scheme for 14 Wellings in the
position marked with the black spot and
here we have it better identified with a
red line on the east side of the
Egyptian Road again on on grazing land
the application as I said is for 14
dwellings here's the red line
we've also we also have a public
right-of-way running through the scheme
here where that where the dotted line is
and that's been an important feature of
of the development which will become
clear a little bit later on so that is a
constraint that we've been working with
the southern part of the site in the
blue line here falls within flood zone -
but as there's no development proposed
there the Environment Agency raises no
objection again it's an allocated site
in the Salford seven and DP and the
arrow point into the scheme the pink
line is the conservation area so the
front of the site is within the
conservation area and the majority of
the built form is is outside of it and
also colored in red are various listed
buildings we have two cottages here
listed which which back onto the site
and we have some Matthews church
in the further distance here we have the
layout 14 it's a mix of detached and 70
touch properties
I'm also proposed and the scheme is an
area of communal parking here because
there's been history of informal parking
along the frontage which isn't ideal
so the rear parking is amantha Preem is
a premium in the area so the developer
has offered a additional area of parking
here the scheme is also compliant with
the NDP policy relating to parking which
is a parking standard slightly above the
average so it is it is providing for or
addressing if you like the parking
issues that have emerged in the village
and they have been accommodated within
the scheme so here we have a street
scene of the dwellings that's looking
back along evesham Road so you can see
the houses just to the right and you'll
just see there peeping peeping in the
distance the church and that takes me
back to the point about the public
right-of-way which crosses the site
there's a very clear Vista as you enter
the gate off evesham Road and start to
proceed along the public right-of-way of
the of the view of the church and the
scheme has been designed to ensure that
the the public footpath remains on its
recorded alignment and the houses are
shifted off to the right so that that
visitor is maintained the actual houses
and cells are fairly straight
straightforward simple sort of cottage
style and we've worked quite a lot on
getting agreement from the developer to
ensure that we get attention to detail
eaves verges we have cambered lintels
brittle in tools so we've gone for
what's called a snapped header double
snapped had a lintel detail which is the
end
bricks forming an arch and they will
project 10 millimeters from the
surrounding brickwork so you start to
get that sense of molding and shadow and
interest in the elevation
we've got chimneys on each of the
dwellings there can they'll be masonry
constructed chimneys are built off the
gable ends which again will add that
sense of character to the development
and help it stitch yourself into into
the into the fabric of the village these
are the sort of typical house types
which will be subject to finer detail by
way of condition as us mentioned looking
up and down the road so there we have a
clear view of the field that's proposed
for the development looking that way and
also looking back out of the village you
can see the gap there and the sight
frontage the the houses on the opposite
side of the road our typical sort of
Victorian houses a short row of terraces
and we'd hope to pick up on the finer
detailing and try and sort of build on
those design cues and and have that
running as a theme across the
development you can see there the the
design line of the public right-of-way
and how it heads up there towards the
church is quite quite a pleasant Vista
and one that will be maintained so the
application recommendation is to approve
subject to section 106 and a number of
conditions and is also an update which
continues to provide members with
further information that were recently
received with regards to compensate
rework for ecology so we had a figure
offsetting figure from the county
ecologist now that may may come in as an
absolute figure to be spent elsewhere
but we've had a started to have disputes
discussion that the
and that I referred to earlier that
actually might be developed not
developed but designed to include
ecological features that would mean you
may have a mix of a contribution plus
some actual physical works that will be
enjoyed by the village and the
development so that's that's to be tied
in with the 106 and there are a number
of other conditions which is that
emerged since the report was written so
yes so that's the recommendation
augmented by that additional
recommendation and your chair thank you
our first speaker is mr. Nigel callow
architect Thank You Nigel you have three
minutes in your own time
good evening chairman and members thank
you for allowing me to speak I'm Nigel
kilo from n & JC design principal
designer on the project speaking in
sports of our clients application on
this allocated site where the principle
of developments has been agreed the site
is set on the western edge of the
village of Sulphur briars and this
application follows detailed
consultations with the neighborhood
Planning Group and officers in addition
to various public presentations to
establish to the locally preferred
scheme presented to you this evening
this proposal incorporates various minor
amendments to the original submission
design and fully takes into account
further comments and observations from
officers to provide a well landscaped
heritage led design solution for the
site this scheme is suited to the
context and constraints of the site and
is appropriate when considered with
clearly defined local need all the
matters that have fully informed the
design adjustments were made to ensure
that all relevant design criteria have
been met satisfying both local and
national planning guidance enhanced
parking provisions have been made for
each and Road residents who currently
lack suitable parking provision although
vehicles using the development site
environs will be able to enter and leave
the development in the forward gear your
planning officer is content with the
quality of design proposals and that it
satisfies your adopted policies and
supplementary planning guidance the
proposal provides a well-balanced
high-quality and cohesive scheme does
not represent over development to the
site and should be considered as wholly
appropriate when considering the
retained and then how to enhanced
biodiverse green spaces set out around
the dwellings which are an intrinsic
part of the proposals key to the design
is the requirement to maintain the
public right-of-way which crosses the
site retaining an open dista to the
village church to the east the scheme
sits in a landscape setting where
openness in glimpsed views between the
buildings creates a relatively informal
and organically at layout arrangement in
which a diverse mix of small to medium
sized family dwellings is provided to
satisfy the established local
requirements with the careful use of
high quality facing materials and
detailing appropriately can
by the case officer the development will
contribute towards the conservation area
character Julie enhancing the setting
this proposal offers no significant harm
or impact in terms of overlooking two
neighbors having carefully considered
the original objections we firmly
believe that there are no material
planning considerations arising from
those matters that would provide
appropriate reasons to refuse the
Planning Commission in conclusion we've
read your officers detailed reports and
fully concur with its recommendations
the scheme provides the developer
seconds which will enhance the visual
quality of the overall street scene this
probe design is both in innovative and
wholly appropriate in the planning
balance with the relevant beneficial
additional contributions being made
they've fully accords with your adopted
policies with due consideration to all
of the matters we've mentioned here
today and with respect to your officers
recommendation we respectfully request
that the application be approved by
members at this evening's meeting thank
you thank you
there must you have any questions if I
may just a couple of points first of all
I noticed that there are no affordable
housing or shared equity scheme on the
side can you just explain why I believe
that it was investigated with local
service providers and that it was felt
that the site was inappropriate similar
to the reasons that were given in the
previous scheme market housing was more
appropriate solution for the site and it
is providing the funds for parking that
is thank you and the rather silly one I
suppose the officer mentioned about the
chimneys are they've real fireplaces in
this not in the properties themselves
our clients have used the GRP based
stacked previously which has brick slips
which are proper clay brick slips on the
outside and the effect is exactly as a
normal sort of fireplace normal chimney
stack so the
in the streets okay thank you any other
questions Cosmo we're just going to
check how fiber from the primary school
for reference it's around about half a
mile no more yeah yeah
any other questions okay thank you very
much right well as I'm not speaking on
this particular item and technical
questions okay no questions I shall open
it up to debate cattle jars I am a
little bit concerned about the detail of
the council conservation officers
concerns about this site and so
essentially what were asked to do here
is say well the sulphate Pryor's
development plan a lot of this site and
is happy with this site and we give that
greater weight but I think I do think
page 27 and 28 do make quite interesting
reading to be honest because I think
it's I it would there's a significant
concern I think from the council's
called the conservation officer about
actually the designated SS Cosmo yes
whether it sustainable site in the
respective citizens from the shops and
those doors which is basically about the
conservation architect's sort of gave
them open country so I do realize those
are my concerns
you said Harper Morrow well that's over
and above the amount that are supposed
to be I have to say approximate but even
so
Anthony can actually model I mean it's
worth just reminding members that this
is identified as a sustainable
settlement in the core strategy and
therefore whilst we can take into
account those two points that has
already been established in the core
strategy as a sustainable settlement and
the principle of allowing the scheme
while not allowing a scheme for
allocating scheme in the NDP has really
gone beyond that consideration having
established that it's a sustainable
settlement you know it sits within the
fabric yeah but the point really is this
appears to me rightly or wrongly I do
say here what you're saying and I've
said what I had to say so okay thank you
chair I do tech take into account what
some councillor Charles have said
certainly in the relation to the
Heritage comments and the balance I mean
I do note that the the officer at the
end of the the section does so taking
into account the community's vision and
objectives and in the beneficial
amendments made they lay after this site
they're satisfied that the public
benefits of the development
significantly and I think significant is
the word here outweigh the less than
substantial harm to the designated
heritage assets I think with the well
established now Neighborhood Development
Plan it obviously fits in there we saw
on the earlier application that is site
is allocated in that plan which performs
part of the core strategy I look at the
design
and I have to say it is less than
inspiring but I'm sure that suitable
conditioning and then detailed work with
the officers and the developer can
overcome that I mean we are looking at a
Warwickshire South Warwickshire village
here so I would like to see housing a
little bit more in keeping they look a
little bit too modern to me but that
surely can be conditioned so on that
basis and again giving weight to the
neighbourhood plan I've looked at the
housing mix it's not brilliant but it's
not there has to be variation we can't
stick to exact percentages and I feel
than in relation to the four bed and the
two and the three bed it seems on
balance they'd be okay this is not a
location for single units of single
bedroom units and I probably argue
against myself it's not one for
two-bedroom either so on that basis I'm
quite happy to go with the officers
recommendation to grant and I would
propose that the if I can find a second
that we go along without I like to
second that proposal members it's just
one point on in the presentation the
applicant suggested that they or seemed
to indicate that the treat that the chip
chimneys would not be masonry
constructed but would in fact be a a
sort of timber frame with brick slips
attached officers have made it clear
right from the start that these should
be masonry constructed chimneys built
off the gable wall so members just need
to decide whether the slip brick slip
idea is something that they are content
with or do they want something more
authentic and also allows the chimney to
be built not as a standard standard
piece but one may have variety in terms
of brick detailing and so on so
for members to consider whether that's
important from their point of view if I
can just add to that I do agree entirely
with that I think that we want to make
it as as authentic and and white for
like us as possible so I will happily go
along with that so just a couple
comments on this one when I first saw
the scheme on on the on the site I must
admit I was a little bit concerned about
the housing and as with council Lawton I
feel that the design is less than
inspiring and I agree with with him on
that one but I know that's a huge amount
of work being put into this design and I
congratulate the officers and the
developers on that particular point I do
feel however that the we must make sure
the conditions are correct that we can
actually ensure that the quality of the
construction is as high as at all
possible I have concerns have the
off-site provision of affordable housing
but I do see the argument it is
something we are fully aware of we need
to do some more work on and finally one
thing that before I stop is that again I
would like to say that fiber optic
provision is made on these these
properties as well as has been requested
by the parish Chad a factor is the view
of the committee and it falls apart to
the recommendation and second as with
the previous application that would be a
valid condition Thank You castle Lawton
you made a proposal you're happy with
those additional conditions yes you've
put some of my mumblings more eloquently
chairman so he can say girls can I just
went because at page 31 there's the sort
of list as you've described of design
features that you would expect to see
come forward it says these details
materials can be secured by way of
planning conditions so is that is that
contained in the planning conditioners
already yes it is is there it's at 11:00
fine so caravans
I think the chimneys have got a look as
they should do in a rural area whether
they use the noise that is a different
matter but in one start we have him well
purred they did actually make them so
they were you
and they do look that much better they
look authentic I have to the trouble of
dating a brick built chimney won't put a
chimney flue in it as well but anyway
that's that's another issue
right so council Orton you know happy
with those conditions which will David
well now say encounter before do you're
happy with those still have been a
second thank you chairman just with Kara
fication you have the conditions on page
thirty seven twenty conditions you also
have the additional fiber optic
condition discussed today you also have
on the updated sheets and additional
five conditions also in terms of the
section 106 page 36 sets out the heads
of terms for the section 106 obligation
and there is also the heads of terms
relating to ecology on the updated sheet
yes okay thank you in that case then
visit we're all happy with that the vote
before used a grant planning permission
for seventeen stars
Oh two four seven five stars for all
those in favor
thank you this committee therefore
resolves to grant planning permission
for 17s - oh two four seven five Sasha
thought thank you
right our next item on the agenda this
evening counselor Barnes is now sitting
out this is 17 / 0 3 7 9 2 / 4 + 17 / 0
3 7 9 3 / LBC listed building consent
this is from Anna farm duck Lane Welford
on Aven Charlotte is a presenting
officer
Thank You chairman the site is indicated
on the map by the black circle the
application site is located in Welford
on Aven on duck lane it is located on
the eastern edge of the village but
within the conservation area which is
defined by the pink line this slide
shows the application site edged in red
again the pink line of the conservation
area can be seen the application site
includes a barn on the northern side of
the site which is great - listed in its
own right
this is shaded in red the manor
farmhouse is also great to lift it and
sited at right angles to the listed barn
fronting onto duck Lane both of these
buildings are listed as significant
buildings within the conservation area
the red line also includes a section to
the south of Mana farmhouse where a new
access in conv car barn would be
proposed a detached residential property
known as awkward is located to the south
with walnut tree cottage located to the
north this is an application for full
planning permission and listed building
consent for the change of years
conversion and extension of the existing
grade 2 listed agricultural barn into
three new dwellings in addition a new
access point and detached car barn would
be positioned on the southern part of
the site following removal of part of
the wall and some of the vegetation
this slide site shows the existing and
proposed North elevations with the
existing elevations shown at the top of
the slide you can see that nine
additional reef lights are proposed as
part of the scheme along with two
additional openings at first floor level
changes to the openings that ground
floor are also shown with a new single
storey extension this slide shows the
existing and proposed South elevations
but the proposed elevations shown at the
bottom of the screen you can again see
the proposed extension now on the
left-hand side of the slide this plan
shows the proposed proposed carvanha
which would measure eight point four
meters and width five meters in depth
and four point nine meters in Heights
with a half hip brief path that part of
the building would be open with Park
gated this photo shows the frontage of
the site when viewed from duck lane you
can see the eastern and southern
elevations of the listed barn
along with manna farmhouse which is
located two left-hand side of the photo
the existing gated access is also shown
here the barn is timber frames with
brick infill and weather-boarding this
photo is taken slightly further south
along duck lane looking back to the
access for the barn conversion the
listed barn is central within the photo
with manna farmhouse again to the left
and the front and side of walnut tree
cottage on the right-hand side of the
photo this photo is taken from the front
of Manor farmhouse facing south along
duck Lane approximately 3.8 meter wide
section of the wall would be removed
along with a group of trees to
facilitate the new accessing car barn
for manna farmhouse this photo has taken
further south along duck lane looking
back towards the application site manna
farmhouse is visible with glimpses of
the barn and walnut tree cottage at the
back of the photo this photo is taken
from within the central courtyard
directly to the south of the bar
the front which is the southern
elevation of the listed barn is visible
on the left-hand side of the photo with
the rear of mana farmhouse visible on
the right-hand side access for the new
dwellings would be from the existing
gated access which is visible centrally
the gravel area would be used for
parking this photos taken panning around
and we're now facing west looking at
again at the southern elevation of the
barn and the weather boarding this photo
shows the west and elevation and the
southern elevation of the barn the
proposed extension would be sited at
this end of the building and would
replace the existing carriage again when
a farmhouse is visible on the right-hand
side
this photo is panned round to show the
rear elevation of mana farmhouse the
gravel Aryan frontage would be used for
parking this photo is panned around
further south facing towards where the
car barn would be sited manna farmhouse
and its existing gated soy garden wallah
visible on the left-hand side with the
residential property known as Oakwood
visible in the rear of the photo this
photo is taken facing east from the
proposed amenity space to the rear of
the bar the rear of walnut tree cottage
is visible on the left-hand side of the
photo with the listed barn on the
right-hand side this photo shows the
northern elevation of the listed barn
the relationship with walnut tree
cottage can again be seen here as this
is the residential property this photo
is taken from the rear garden of walnut
tree cottage facing south towards the
listed barn just to clarify there are
some updates noted within the update
sheet officer recommendation is to
refuse the applications for full
Planning Commission and listed building
consent for the reasons unknown which
can be found on pages 56 to 58 of the
agenda thank you
thank you sure our first speaker is
coughs Islamic culture Welford parish
council walk we don't often enough but
actually our tecnine usual step was
speaking on this form because the parish
council position on heritage assets like
this is we quite often want the
development but of course we generally
defer to the conservation officers but
this one's a little bit different in the
sense that they've been multiple changes
to the to the proposed developments and
actually this is a fantastic bomb that
does need to be brought back into you
know good use as it were it is in line
the developments have you look at the
normal planning application is in line
today as ten cs20 acs to anybody eighty
four of the local eight NDP and they
tell you five of the local NDP and
actually we'd like to see them brought
back in to reduce actually sensitively
and we've definitely support you know
sensitive and restoration of heritage
assets this asset does actually split
quite nicely into two units if you go
into the building you lets you see
there's a sort of central spine with an
old brick written and they you know the
internal sort of wooden frame and
actually knocking that through into a
single property I think that you will do
more damage to the property then the old
complete damage that you saw at the end
is a realized soul and I mean actually
part of this development is actually to
take that away and put it as a small
single-story extension at the back there
I think the Garrety has been up for
about 30 or 40 years or so so actually
that's that's a good thing there's lots
of positive things around this I know
there's a site development site visit
this afternoon that I know not many
people could actually manage to get to
it but it is worth having a look at this
you know and I would definitely sort of
encourage that and so to finish the
parish council do support the
development of this property we do defer
to the conservation offices our policy
however if you are minded to refuse this
application I do think it's worth
actually getting out there and having a
look at it yourselves and so it might be
appropriate to if however you are minded
to support it then one thing that we
would request and we're going to request
this on every application in in Welford
is that we have a very good construction
management plan put in place in advance
thank you thank you just the point
you mentioned about I should say that I
fully intended to come to the site visit
day but yes I couldn't make it which was
quite frustrating for me however you
mentioned that the as you walk in this
to make two sections you felt it was
better I think you could do two easily
yeah I think actually would be better
with two the wrong one breaks this
central wall but essentially yeah I mean
I've I know the building is I know the
applicant's father I mean I used to
tinker with it in that place and
actually there's a central sort of wall
with a wooden frame above it and
actually you'd have to pray that
breakthrough that somehow to much make
it into a single dwelling so I don't
think a single dwelling is and I'm
really appropriate and I know the detail
here is the devil is in the detail with
these sorts of things I fully understand
that but the principle of development is
something that we definitely support
just pick on that particular point
because in the in the it is conversion
into to create three dwellings yes
yeah of course the principle of bringing
these buildings into life if it's
capable but in a way that doesn't would
you agree that actually we've got I mean
I'm taking you've read what the
conservation officer says from 47 to 49
I mean my view provisionally at the
moment is that that's quite substantial
criticism because there's quite a lot of
things that are missing for example we
don't even have a report from a
structural engineer to confirm whether
the barn is capable of conversion we
don't have much of an assessment as to
how the fabric and layout would be
affected flooring there's quite a lot of
criticism would you agree with me that
what we don't want is a sense of rushing
into you know what we want the thing to
be brought back into life so let's skip
over the detail and actually you know
maybe your representation of parish
counts of being a bit hasty in terms of
you know whether we've actually got it
right yet
I mean I appreciate that actually I
think the structural integrity of the
building will be fine it's actually a
very good condition and if you look at
the woodwork
I don't think there's any wood room in
any of this hardly which is amazing for
a building like that
I do appreciate though that's probably
actually you know maybe it is an
important step that actually should be
there so that you can actually I mean
that should be any other questions thank
you very much Augusta thank you
right our next speakers are Jutland
Stiles and Nicholas Butler and you have
six minutes between you if you want to
come up to the tables please you're more
than welcome and have you decided how
you can split the time you have six
minutes total between the two of you you
get it and you get a posse you don't
have to it's okay Nicholas it's
perfectly all right thank you okay the
conversion of traditional agricultural
buildings into houses inevitably
involves a loss of character but it is
far better to convert than lose them
altogether so this has to be accepted on
the strength of the submitted plans of
this development I'm certain that the
proposed conversion would completely rob
this old bond if it's essential
character and identity the crammed two
hustles into this building would be
absurd to cram three hustles into it
utterly so to say nothing of the
problems with access and parking and
were this application allowed policies
cs8 in the core strategy and AC fall in
the willful or knave and neighbourhood
plan and all the other policies that
insist that every physical change must
be for the better would count for
absolutely nothing
this building is a listed building and
it stands in a Conservation Area the
utmost care must therefore be taken to
preserve the character of the building
and the character of the locality
instead is proposed to emasculate this
beautiful timber frame
by pockmarking it with fussy a gleam
demonstration evidently to make as much
profit as possible
never mind the physical result the
proposal is tasteless completely
insensitive and thoroughly irresponsible
and I urged this committee to reject it
now let's 1/2 minutes but I also have a
doctrine that I'd like to pass out to
members of your committee it is simply a
drawing of the bond as it is now as it
appears on the website unfortunately we
don't allow that now because I have no
time for this you watch themselves they
don't allow you to say that the drawing
of the barn is very very faint what
could happen to it is in Brooklyn
beautiful Technicolor and absolute
detail but as you'd see on that pan
there the the drawing of the barn as it
stands is very very Peter can hardly be
made out and that seems to be a feature
of studio Spicer that's what they do the
two other applications
at the moment waiting to be decided by
this District Council one of them is 17
stroke double 1700 to 203 and again the
drawings of what is there on the site
cannot be made out it is a trick that
they use right can I just drop this we
aren't now I appreciate this is an
opportunity for you two to discuss and
discuss this particular application but
not the architect so could you just
stick to the actual substance of the
application please tonight well I've
said what I can and I don't need to be
per survived thank you very much indeed
okay
just move the microphone a little closer
so I'm Jacqueline Stiles I'm
representing my mother and brother who
live at one actually cottage the places
principally affected we agree we'd all
agree with a board member that listed
barns can't fall into disrepair but
better can be done we feel than with
this application for three houses which
is a total of nine bedrooms local
support has been solicited on the basis
that the conversion is for the personal
use of the applicants who require three
extra houses in order to stay at manna
farm however I don't believe the
applications being put in for personal
use I'm not aware that it has so
therefore these houses sold mean at
least six extra cars going through
congested Chapel Street and coming via
meniscus and residents have submitted
objections on this basis the design in
the scope of the application creates
unacceptable an invasion of privacy for
my family due to the extreme proximity
of the two buildings the varnas
Charlotte showing you the barn runs the
whole length of the garden right up to
the back of the cottage and the
elevation that affects walnut tree
cartridges the North elevation and the
application proposes seven sets of
French windows utility doors opening
onto that tiny space 2.5 metres from the
cottage boundary which would then out
look over the whole garden in the rear
windows at the cottage
I asked what lighting and noise would
result from these seven back doors
exiting from three homes
the only separation is a patchy hedge
big patchy hedge that the applicant
seeks to reduce it she's been in touch
with my mother about it on the first
floor would be windows that would
overlook the cottage and the garden I
think some of them are prescribed as
obscured I don't know enough about these
things that presumably windows open and
obscuring can be negated not all of them
would actually be obscured across the
whole range of the house
and also to mention and Charlotte said
currently the roof space has no window
punctuation at all there be nine nine
new sets of windows along the the roof
space and my mom's refer to it as
looking like a block of flats I think
she has a point
so I'm just around out we object this
application for the same reason as
planning and conservation over
development of the barn and privacy
invasion of the cottage as it fails to
comply with the council policy on
separation distances I think has been
detailed in in the planning offices
report I think the it needs to be a
minimum of 10 meters and it's a minimum
of three so I believe manna barn is in
good repair excellent repair due to the
applicants parents conservation of it
over the years and I just wanted to say
about conversion once Dan green with the
counselor cannot be undone and a more
considered and modest proposal would
have been appropriate in every respect
thank you thank you thank you very much
indeed if you just press the button at
the bottom thank you thank you right our
next speaker there as he goes is Oliver
Spicer and Nicola Bromley
good evening a proposed development
involved a change of use of land of
elicited former agricultural building to
three houses the building is located
within the settlement boundary of
welfare Navin so there should be no
object and principle to this development
we've provided detailed diagrams that
demonstrate that there's no overlooking
or privacy issue proposed was made the
council's policy for minimum separation
distances from amenity of naval and
properties the main issue is heritage
I've many years of experience converting
more buildings to houses I've carefully
drawn these plans with the sensitivity
to the historic character of the
building and I've taken into account
best practice guidelines in particular
those which outline the district design
guide those which outline in historic
England publication of adapting
traditional farm buildings these in turn
accept that changes and an intervention
tool it to an existing listed building
in order to convert them to a house
we'll have some have some harm
applications such as these are
individual and unique the manner of the
proposed conversion is a matter of
professional skill and care and its
success is based on its professional
opinion I stand by the quality of the
sensitivity of these plans unfortunately
I have a different opinion to that the
conservation officer clearly it is a
difficult position but we put you in
tonight to arbitrate on these these
matters therefore I invite you to
consider the following options firstly
you can agree with me that perhaps we
prepared the conversion of issues
designed with sensitivity and care
secondly if you do not wish to challenge
this assessment the conservation officer
or the global authority is possible to
grant comfort permission and taking into
account public benefits that outweigh
any harm the long-term preservation of a
listed building that will otherwise fall
into disrepair as many as others have in
this area creation of small houses in a
sustainable location that are required
and have a specific need to support the
district housing land supply and the
creation of employment during its
conversion conversion and the ongoing
maintenance of these properties the more
local residents in this area the
sustainable
that would provide economic benefits to
the existing shops and services in
Welford there'll also be enough
financial payments and new homes bonuses
to local authority completion to seal
the retention of the remaining listed
building and its likelihood have been
maintained thoroughly with the new
occupiers there's local support from the
parish in 39 there's local support from
the ward member and many local residents
these public benefits are considerable
in my opinion outweigh any harm that's
been identified by the conservation
officer I vote you to grant patient
tonight and you using these benefits as
yule reason
Thank You chairman good evening Oliver
just one point just looking at the
elevations on there I mean all of the
fenestration in the in the roof is is on
the southern elevation and obviously
there is a a concern there about
overlooking the cottage opposite what
why he put them on that elevation rather
than on the northern elevation would
just like me to be as less nuisance to a
neighbor and have better or or less
impact on overlooking as it will be
overlooking an existing yard is the
reason for my answer that in a couple of
ways firstly the gardens I mentioned
earlier from how to England in
converting listed buildings or barns
they except there was some harm so one
of the things that in converting this
barn we've we've only in in installed
new windows or doors in existing
openings other than two positions where
there are bedrooms that we need a very
small window to be a fire escape natural
light to these other rooms but I've got
very contrived window position because
it's a listed building the barn come
from the roof light which is the policy
which is supported through these their
heritage England document however when
you're doing intervene in a building of
this nature use of course the minimum
impact to provide the provision of use
but in this case the minimum impact has
put them on the back of the property so
when it's seen as a collective of the
other buildings it's its frames on the
farm courtyard these aren't visible so
this is the back elevation of the barn
if I may ask the planning officer there
was a photograph that you brought up
earlier looking from the neighboring
property at this elevation and with this
in mind if you take this view there's a
just a shot thought was very that just a
shot you just had there so that's the
view so on the roof there will be some
roof lights nevertheless you're very
unlikely to see any of the window
positions that along that elevation onto
that side of the building and it also is
is that is the the back of the barn of
an agricultural bar in terms of each use
so that's the primary reason that
they've been allocated to that side of
the property okay thank you
you haven't really answered my question
is there any actual physical
constructional reason why they couldn't
be on the northern elevation to provide
the satellite there wasn't necessarily
instructional practical reason what we
couldn't install them but in terms of
impacts on the listed building on its
setting it would be more detrimental to
be on the front of the building than on
the rear of the building okay I
understand Thanks
any other questions thank you very much
next speaker is Casa Vance
Birbal hasn't started yet really okay
this is a beautiful old bond that I have
had shape in in the past and it was used
in the war effort for recycling and it
is in very good condition because the
lady whose husband parents lived there
have kept it you know as good as they
can this listed we want to save it the
person that spoke against it said that
you know it is in good condition and we
have looked at it I looked at it today
with the two offices they hadn't looked
at it before if you look at the first
window that has got stone pebbles floor
go a little bit further way after the
ramp and we have what's called a
pitching floor we then go on to the
furthest to the bond which is the length
which is wooded you can see it at the
end there which has beautiful blue slab
floor now there is a number of concerns
in the conservation architect and the
one concerned is that the big barn at
the end there where all the Woolies
shouldn't have a floor in it now we went
in there today and I did say that if I
was in there with a wood-burning stove
to keep it warm it's that big you burned
the Forest of Arden in no time at all so
as far as I'm concerned farm conversions
you can see how big the bomb is it's not
big enough it's too big for one person
it is it's a big bomb it's a big
building and both officers were
surprised at the size of it whether it's
got stuff in it with the floor the roof
we looked at the bottle and dor-win
there if you come back to where they
first gone in not this end but the
middle end we've got 14
seventy-two 6272 fully born brick in
there which she's not got more to in
them you know me beautiful thing there
is a lot of things in there that I
believe as a committee you should go and
look at it
I appreciate there are some windows and
I went round next door there a you list
you went down next door I did myself and
we did on the site visit and I
appreciate the concern of the lady next
door but we appreciate that but at the
moment as far as I can see the distances
of the existing windows to the house
under the limit
can be that the other windows that are
going in the roof are more than the
chain apart going through the other
thing one of the other things that the
officer didn't like was the extension at
the end if you can show the garage which
is a if you like there it is I call it a
a Bambury concrete garage EB see what I
mean which really isn't suited to the
area and the applicant is decided to put
on a small extension on the concrete
they're smaller in size than the actual
garages at the moment
which i think is a major improvement if
we can go to the next door and there is
concern that both they were although if
you put the sudden one on again back
again the other side you will see that
all those windows and all those spaces
in that building that you look up are
there anymore they are there now and so
in that respect it is within Polly
planning policy we go back to next door
if you like that one picture where the
hedges if we were to agree and I think
we should agree that's what we do would
want a condition on that page to say
that it was kept at it's two and a half
meters we've made
did he needs to be two meters high to
say God that you can't see them but
there are two little windows there took
10 or 15 foot along and then about 20
foot along which will obviously be used
if it's living which aren't they aren't
really used at the moment but there are
two windows which are two foot long
about a big is disabled
well I was going down to say was we got
an application we did have a no not that
one but I'll do that one first
that's the listed building with the
consent of the Gloucester diocese they
went on that land there which was set
next to a great one listed building
cancer can I ask you to finish now Busan
your five minutes are up I said tell me
at four minutes I do that that that has
been left empty for two years because
the conservation architect aren't agree
when the fish above Gloucester was very
happy that was one of the pictures I
gave you that the Shakespeare is now 89
years ago they wanted to adapt that for
bed and breakfast did you like two years
ago if they couldn't get it thank you
very much new cancer right thank you
come on
Thank You chairman councillor Bantz
I was conscious of the comment from the
parish council about their view that the
building would be perhaps better to be
divided into two dwellings rather than
three and there was a very persuasive
argument that the the structure of the
building as it is would lend itself to
that and then what you'll be your cones
on that if an application came forward
to preserve this building but only with
two dwellings rather than the three
well it certainly yeah he's too big for
one billing so the answer be I would
obviously look at it but be happy to but
he certainly if we go back to the
building it's three times the size of
this building and they won't be for bed
and breakfast in there okay thanks I
think about you are you making the
suggestion that even though this
proposal breaches the separation
distances on top lower as well
the 21 metres away from the house the
windows that are going to be put in
extra in the roof the allocated distance
from there now what I was suggesting was
that those two windows there and they're
about the size of this table which you
can't see well they you can't see them
look yep all right that they should be
frosted glass and a conditioned foot on
that they hate to be if you like kept it
to meters now all the other windows you
can see a well away from the 21 meters
which is the legal requirement thank you
thank you
are they technical questions just
character I think that the point about
its impact on the neighboring building
is probably my biggest concern
I think building regs whatever I think
probably would address counselor Jones's
because his price is not an engineering
destructor report I'm showing you Rama
so just clarification these two windows
that do they overlook are they in breach
of policy are there ways to mitigate
that or is it if one did approve this
are we accepting there would be sort you
know more than we would like
impact on the neighboring building the
council's extending your home planning
advice now requires there to be 10 meter
separation distance from any first-floor
window which would overlook a neighbor's
garden the distances from the closest
wind days along this elevation at first
floor level would be approximately three
meters away from the hedge at the
maximum these three windows here which
is an answer window for a bedroom and
then an ensuite and a further bathroom
have been noticed on the plan as being
obscurely glazed however it could be
that the windows could still be opened
which would obviously are now over
looking into that garden area because of
the three meter separation distance I
just add as welcome I mean mention has
been made of the hedge no hedges are
transient features as members know
they're not permanent features my
understanding is the ownership of the
hedge is unclear so we're not sure
whether the edges under the ownership of
the applicant or the neighbor now
clearly if it is not under the ownership
of the applicant it would be
unreasonable to put a condition
requiring the retention to a two meter
height it wouldn't pass all the tests
put a condition down so one thing to see
if Charlotte would correct me on the
ownership but I'm don't believe it can
get certeyn who owns that hedge and as I
say you could put a condition down and
if you don't raise for whatever reason
you're left there with something that's
lower than the two meters so I'm not
sure how realistic was they understand
the sentiment of why councilor Barnes
has mentioned that I couldn't assure you
of the realistic nature of such a
condition
that was my question how can you
condition the henge in perpetuity Castle
Thank You chairman Charlotte could you
just for the sake of me and everybody
help you could you just indicate on this
elevation where are the existing windows
I think we're all pretty convinced that
the the skylights are all new and you've
pointed out the three on the left-hand
side I presume the two on the right-hand
side and well the third the right-hand
side in you but what's existing so yes
you are right in saying that all of the
roof lights longest elevation so all
nine roof lights would be new this is an
existing opening which obviously
translates that window this is an
existing opening as well as well as this
one so the new first-floor windows are
this one here and this one here okay so
just those two I see it's cool because
you go to Specsavers thank you thank you
any other technical questions again just
confused there with the parish council
it seemed I couldn't work out whether
this was I know the note says it's
3-bedroom but I think the impression I
got was the sort of core bomb was gonna
be too and there was a bit of an
extension over there
replacing the garage which is the third
is that incorrect is is the core barn
being divided into three yes that's
right the existing barn will be
converted into three dwellings they're
proposed extension is part of one of
those dwellings layout of how the I
don't think we've seen the lay of how
the the floor layouts are actually
designed
so these are the existing ground and
first floor plans and these are the
proposed ground in first full puns so
the units are proposed so this is the
first unit here this is the second unit
here and the third units over here so
there's one t-bird one three bad and one
for bed proposed okay thank you any
other technical questions just one then
is the conservation officer saying that
there is less than substantial harm
that's correct the conservation officer
has summarized that there's some higher
end of lesson substantial harm as a
result of the proposal the public
benefit is that we can base our
decision-making on at present there is
no there is no evidence the bond is
about to fall into disrepair and clearly
and I think the gentleman
CPRA mention it the last thing we want
is to lose our traditional buildings and
one of the ways forward is to convert
such buildings into residential or
employment use now clearly the more
residential units are going to the barn
the more the possibility of alterations
whether through building regulations
through needing to get light and
ventilation to certain rooms and now
there are certain ways you can go about
the conversion do you want to try and
avoid residential features like chimneys
which is clearly a domestic appear
which is very rare to get on
agricultural buildings likewise domme
windows so what are the ways forward as
you've seen in this presentation is to
show rooflines
but as to whether or not the barn is an
immediate risk of getting into disrepair
I looked at the site today and I thanked
the applicants and the agent for showing
me around so I haven't seen it before
and from my perspective there was no
immediate risk
thank you chair again just what are you
afflicting through those look you just
flashed for a nanosecond the elevation
of the the proposed new extension I
think it's the elevation looking that's
it okay so that's that's what it's
that's glasses it curtain glazing this
here would be glazed glazed
okay okay thank you we obviously have to
place great weight on preserving listed
buildings they we Planning Department is
a custodian as is the applicant and the
owner and in my view whilst of course
we're looking to make sure that
buildings are brought into life if they
can be clearly what the aim is to ensure
that there is preservation of the
features and in many ways I think this
committee or quite properly be to be
reliant on the expert opinion because
the reality is
none of us are architectural historians
or conservation officers we don't have
that training and this report in my view
is very detailed as to the reasons why
this isn't an appropriate proposal I
think it's worth pointing out on page 48
that it says in working buildings the
extent of the survival is comparatively
rare and no doubt instigated the Barnes
listing in its own right so in other
words this is a rare example of of a
barn of this substance and quality and
age existing as it has done and in my
view that calls therefore for thee if
there is if there does need to be reuse
I mean obviously a bond can just be
maintained and kept in its own
circumstance as perfectly possible but
if it does need to be reused and for the
desire for that obviously you want to
have a consensus on how that is done if
possible now there is we clearly a long
way from consensus this isn't a case
where actually the conservation officer
says well I'm 90% in agreement I'm just
a bit concerned about this or that the
conservation officer makes serious
criticisms and as we've heard this is
put on the scale of a high end of less
than substantial harm
clearly the I think just looking at it
one can see that the fenestration will
hugely change the character of that
building it's it's beautiful in its
simplicity it looks like a cultural it's
in keeping with the whole of its
surroundings it gives us an insight into
what that property was and what it did
and and I think what is there by the
conservation officer at page 47 to 49 is
is really compelling in my view now
clearly actually in terms of where we're
guided is that actually if we were going
to approve this we would actually need
to have that need to be significant
public benefit well in my view there's
absolutely no justification for that
whatsoever
we know that Welford has a
and we have currently a perfectly good
land supply Welford has taken it it's no
more than its number of houses really by
definition of the core strategy there's
no pressing need for extra houses it's
not really a proper argument so in my
view it would be a complete dereliction
of our duty to approve this application
in light of the very very strong and
well reasoned advice we've been given to
us by the experts who advisers on top of
that there is the additional reason of
adverse impact on neighboring amenity so
and again that's a really important
thing those neighbors are already there
and this is in clear and explicit breach
of our own our own policy
it's obviously always very difficult to
try and bring listed buildings back into
into uses it's it's it takes a lot of
thought and negotiation but in my view
this report shows a very long way from
that with this suggestion I do
I propose refusal I do agree with you I
I have to say that I agree in principle
to the development I think you've said
quite eloquently about the issues with
the fenestration and suchlike
and that's importantly the overlooking
so I I quite agree with you and I'm
happy to second that
Thank You chair um I'll be a bit
negative the things that don't like is I
don't like the extension it's completely
out of character I can't believe that
anybody would think that that would pass
any Planning Committee and I don't like
the southern roof lights however the
principle of developing this fine
building from a redundant agricultural
building into residential seems to me to
be perfectly in in accordance with our
core strategy and I think more
sympathetically done
if it came back to this committee
without the extension and was perhaps
two houses it's already pointed out that
it's a very big building so we've got
plenty of space to build two good-sized
buildings without utilizing all of the
upper floors which would probably mean
we wouldn't have the fenestration so I
would support Molly's proposal because
this is not quite right yet I'm pleased
that the building is in good condition
because there's plenty of time for it to
come back with a better proposal okay
thank you are there any other right well
then members we do have a proposal in a
seconder for this remembers the vote
before you through a few spline
permission now I'm going to take them
both separately which is 17 - oh three
seven nine two four and then 17 - oh
three seven nine three sash LBC so the
first one is refused confirmation for
1703 792 stars for all those in favor
that's thank you and 417 - oh three
seven nine three / lbc all those refused
this committee therefore resolved
refused permission for 17 star zero
three seven nine two social and
seventeen such oh three seven nine three
/ LBC thank you all right moving I'm
going to take a break for a moment just
so we can have a quick combo break and
get the refreshments
right is everybody back let's serve
restart the proceedings thank you the
next item on the agenda is 17 - oh -
three one five sauce out and that James
presenting Thank You chair so as denoted
by the black dot the application site is
located within the village of those wood
it forms part of the linear row of
dwellings and it's situated within the
West Midlands Greenbelt the application
seeks outline permission for the
demolition of an existing bungalow the
subdivision of the plot and the
subsequent construction of to one and a
half storied wines is noted that
permission is sought for access layout
and scale however appearance in
landscaping or reserve the future
consideration so here we have an aerial
photograph of the sites just there
outlined in red and shows a linear form
of the the current street this is the
proposed layout if you can see here on
the the dotted the dashed line that's
the existing bungalow to be demolished
which spreads across the width of the
site then the subdivision of the plot to
create the two dwellings this just shows
it in context as a site plan here we can
just indicate it's one one and a half
story across the whole breadth of each
EX products makes the dwellings this is
the existing elevations wide bungalow at
four point four meters and the proposed
elevations as I said at the moment
appearance is reserved is reserved for
future consideration so this is really
for the scale this is just some photos
now just to just to show the site this
is from the front elevation and the same
but from the other side because there's
obviously the conifers in the wedding
present this is the street scene photo
taken from a couple of doors down just
here at this red dot just showing the
eclectic mix of the street scene really
ranging from bungalows two-story
dwellings and doormen one and a half
stories and this is from the actual
corner of the existing bungalow just
showing that the variations there in the
roof
Heights to the south and if we look in
towards the site to the next from the
next-door neighbor
and this is looking to the north and
these are these both both properties
here a dormer bungalow in nature this is
the access point here on the existing
the existing a bungalow and this is just
opposite this is again just to show the
the range of properties and this is the
opposite access point cuz konasana on a
u-shape and will be it will form unit
one and there we go thank you oh sorry
the recommendation is for approval
subjects of the conditions outlined on
page 72 of the committee agenda
thank you very much Jane and can I just
question the reason for this being
brought to committee it was a parish
council objection and they're not
speaking this evening that's correct
okay then counter Hawkinson you're on
what of every view yeah I think that
gives a good idea there chairman of what
the area is like as they also have said
the only reason this has brought before
is because of the parish councils
objections which are listed on page 63
unfortunately the agent couldn't be here
he had a pre commitment and apologizes
for absence but it couldn't be avoided I
haven't heard anything from the 12
members of the parish council as to why
they have not been able to find a
volunteer to come and make that case but
if you look on page 63 of their
objections to it the first one
inappropriate development in the
Greenbelt well we have in the town with
Ward had a number of applications of a
very very light nature one was fairly
recently where the development was the
retention of
house but development on either side
there was no objection raised to that in
fact the expression was no
representations the specific factor
which they do mention is the adverse
impact on the Greenbelt well you can see
from the side of the street scene you
can see there it blends in this is quite
an enormous plot without any doubt and I
think one comment has been made about
the volume factor or in further and
further it well the increased volume
here is only 26 percent compared with
the existing structure which of course
is well within whatever parameter we've
had and certainly the old 30 percent
which is big now being eliminated to me
it provides an opportunity to give
increased accommodation without any harm
to the openness of the Greenbelt there
are no neighbor objections and I cannot
really see any valid reasons why this
has has happened in a number of
applications of their similar nature in
my ward should not be wholly endorsed
and I hope members do that I'll accept
the officers recommendation to grant
Thank You councillor are there any
questions of calvinism Thank You
Catherine I will go to technical
questions in that case I will go to
debate the council of Lawton Thank You
chair we're only here because town with
an ardent parish council objected if you
look at their objections inappropriately
under the Greenbelt no it isn't
demolition one bungalow become the
constructor of do drugs or smoking some
infield event of course it does two
dwellings arbiterly large on the
zigzagging button below well that goes
without saying no special circumstance
is not needed adverse impact on the
great scene no impact whatsoever harm to
the efforts of the Greenbelt no harm
whatsoever so I'd go with the officers
recommendation propose we grant this
right I'm just with us thank you very
Council
do I have a
seconder for that kasib and I'm quite
happy to second and it's just very
annoying again when they perish all this
paperwork in the Parish Council
everything I think there is a bit of
history to this this is not the first
time that the parachute failed to turn
off when they have brought it to
committee which is very disappointing
for all of us members we have a proposal
on the second day to accept the
recommendation of for wood this is for
17/2 three one five shot out after the
grant transmission all those in favor
thank you this committee therefore
resolves to grant a plan permission for
1783 one for such thank you right the
next item on the agenda Thank You
councillor Atkinson is 18 - Oh Oh for
three 6/4 and 18500 four three seven /l
BC the lodge the green husband and James
is presenting Thank You chair again so
as denoted by the black dots the
application site is located within the
village of Alveston the proposal seeks
for planning permission unlisted
building consents for the demolition of
the existing conservatory and
construction of a single-story rear
extension the removal of a partition
wall at first floor the demolition of a
courtyard wall repairing the repair work
of existing stucco render and the
planets meant of painted finishes a pair
of existing windows doors making good
fireplaces and chimneys and the removal
of bathroom Suites and cupboards a
number of internal external works then
here's just shows the aerial photograph
with the earth the arrow there pointing
to the sites as it fronts on to the rook
the Rookery here to the north and this
is kissing tree lane south so this is
the the the site plan just showing the
extent of the proposed extension and
it's wrap around in nature towards the
rear elevation this is the detailed
existing site plan but if I move on this
in the first instance we show these
elevations show the remove
all of the conservatory which is coming
coming off here on the front elevation
but yeah this is wise move in towards
that this shows the existing ground
floor plan and as you can see this this
is the wraparound extension they're
looping looping up into this gap just
marginally removing some of this
courtyard area which become clear in the
photos and then replacing it there and
again once again you see the removal of
the conservatory on this elevation so
there's some changes as well in the
existing first floor plan majority is a
internal obviously the one thing I'll
point out here is what is in the
outlined in the Eva Fewell reason and
that is the conservation officers
concern regarding the demolition of the
wall at first floor level so this this
plan does shows which all that's
referring to and here we got the
elevations just met in association with
the the photographs at the site as well
so you can see this is the extension
coming off the back of this elevation
here and then this is the courtyard area
that I mentioned previously and the the
extension facing towards that elevation
of the property that's just the existing
photo enlarged and this is obviously
where the existing conservatory is going
to be removed the two arrow points here
just show the width of the extension so
this is approximately here where the
extension will begin is set back
slightly off this wall and extends out
in this direction and then this is where
that courtyard area will be will be
demolished um we modified as parts the
part of the works so this is the street
scene from from this side here so the
extension effectively will wrap around
in behind here very limited views from
this side and this is the front
elevation again the conservatory element
is actually behind this vegetative board
boundary here and very difficult to see
and this is just again the close up from
from this salivation point with the
extension starting behind discouraging
and it is proposed as well to have
police screening along the shared
boundary oh there's been previous
concerns regarding the removal
trees which have been removed but their
their forwards combat that they've
proposed at the police screening along
this boundary fence and simile along
this along this boundary also so the
application is proposed to be refused as
per the reasons outline within the
committee report thank you before we
carry on I could just go back to the
wall and the courtyard or the courtyard
that's it and you're saying that that
particular wall is coming down yes this
this is part this forms part of the the
actual if I go to the this plan there so
that that wall is that they're
effectively so this is part of the new
extension so it opens up and get
demolishes at wall they are additions
future additions so this will be more
open open in nature but the wall you
refer to is this one here okay thank you
all right thank you our our first
speaker then is Elliot a good old sorry
yes the architect agent no other
speakers
good evening
applause just carry on please don't stop
you waking me awake forever
this cottage which is great too is of a
particularly unique architectural style
and to Stratford more so than its
character in general the Gothic style is
most notably discernible from the to
street side elevations the Northeast and
the northwest which I think the
photographs have shown previously which
provide particularly ornate stucco work
including lovely trifle pattern over the
central gable the style is consistent
with the Gothic Revival cottage that was
fashionable generate 2nd quarter of the
19th century and the southern elevations
which you've also seen are less ornate
constructed from painting brick and in
both cases have been heavily affected by
unsympathetic 20th century fenestration
and extensions which harm the setting of
the original building this is both the
pastiche and poor construction methods
which have actually created physical
deterioration of the building in parts
and also they blur the distinction
between what was the original building
and what is the future additions this
application forms the third iteration of
this scheme we've worked closely with
the ABA to try and reduce the previous
much larger extension and much more
extensive internal interventions to
search that the application is now for
much smaller extension which sits
predominantly on the footprint of the
20th century rear extension although it
does extend real woods slightly it also
removes the unsympathetic conservatory
which has
far-reaching impact on the setting of
the building from its Street elevations
this is an enhancement rather than a
negative impact but furthermore the the
internal changes are now such that we
are essentially proposing the removal of
an internal petition upstairs which I
might add is 20th century it does divide
a previously much larger room and a
small opening a small extension of the
circles place the window in the really
gable which is also a later addition to
the building maintaining vitality of
heritage assets is a specified material
consideration in the MPP F this
application is developed so it will
ensure the longevity and the maintained
maintenance of the vitality of this very
spectacular and pretty cottage we don't
see why there is any harm I just ask one
question in the report and the reason is
a refusal it does take the times about
the extension which i think is one of
the elements and the
uncharacteristically utilitarian and
functional appearance your comments on
that please and the I might add it is a
subjective opinion and whilst we have
taken an approach some people might not
like it is completely in line with the
English Heritage decay publication from
that refers the title building in
context which actually encourages the
introduction of juxtapositions and
adding variety and texture to heritage
assets to further enhance their setting
by creating that delineation and that's
particularly why we've taken this
approach
right thank you that's very kind thank
you thank you
there our next speakers counts are off
members of the committee it's unusual
for me to be here speaking in support of
an application you'll notice also that
there's no one here from the Alpha stand
villagers Association as they are happy
for me to speak on their behalf
the ABA have met with the applicant and
agent and are happy with what is being
proposed but more so they are happy that
someone is taking great care to bring
the house back into its use without
ruining its appearance if they weren't
happy they'd be here making it known as
you know from previous applications in
the village a few weeks ago I went to
see this property and had a look around
inside and out currently the house is
uninhabitable what the applicant wants
to do with this house is bring it back
as much as possible to what it was like
when it was first built retaining all
corner Singh fireplaces and windows and
doors
the current kitchen is rather small as
in an older type house and by building a
single extension out makes it bigger
they will be removing very little of the
wall and are happy of the committee wish
to paint the window friend to same color
as the original the proposed wall to be
knocked down is not the original wall
which is where I believe there is some
confusion the original wall we kept and
the kitchen extension will work around
it but there's going to be like a wall
in the middle of the kitchen with like
an opening it's really very unusual the
owners are removing at gastly 70s PVC
conservatory which you can see from the
road the small extension of the back
will not be seen from the road but in
these works it will also allow the
applicant to restore the beautiful
listed window on the upper landing so
you see the owners really do care about
this property and in my opinion it will
look rather lovely when finished inside
and out I believe it's better to have
someone who truly cares about keeping as
much of the interior and exterior as
possible and become a good neighbor in
this instance only I would ask that you
approve the application
and allow someone to bring this house
back to as near as possible to its
original conception thank you thank you
can sir can I just ask the same question
in the reasons for refusal the utility
of Italian utilitarian the element of
the extension is mentioned as being one
of the major factors against or for
refusal can you comment on that yes I
can because in in the old-style house
the original kitchen is very tiny like
all houses they have the kind of burglar
at one end and all they want to do is
build this extension out keep the wall
or most of it and bring it round so it's
like it's just very very unusual they
are happy to it's going to be within
keeping they're going to use the same
coloring of the walls they are happy to
do whatever you wish into well within
reason they leave them if you want the
windows painted blue like the original
they'll keep it blue but they're working
so hard if you were to actually see
inside this house you will see how much
they are trying very hard it's very
unusual you know I'm not normally here
supporting an Spicer application but in
this system I think Elliot's done a
fantastic job and the applicant has been
so conscious of keeping all its original
features and I think it will work you
won't see that ghastly and the neighbors
are loving it nobody's objecting in the
village thank you the picture of the
wall up so the wall that we're looking
at now is not the original wall
all right thank you sorry about that
any other questions Carol that technical
questions
Kalavati just one for me
so this description here about this
utilitarian and kerosene utilitarian
would you concur with the comment was
made that that is a very subjective
comment not saying it's wrong I'm just
saying is it subjective design generally
is a subjective issue the use of the
word utilitarian is is drawn from the
conservation officers comments which can
be seen throughout the report I think
she draws on the fact that utilitarian
and functional but in terms of
subjectivity design is a subjective
matter just a chair just for my own
experience obviously I have a great to
listen house that has a very modern
juxtaposition glass room on it which I
want to clear won an award from
Stratford history Council so I'm just
wondering if there are other examples
you're aware of where there is that just
a position and this council has happily
supported it or do we normally reject
such applications I can't give you
specific examples chairman but I think
it is correct to say that there is not a
sling objection to a contemporary
approach it doesn't have to be a
pastiche I think the agent actually drew
on that and I would concur with that
that it doesn't actually have to be
traditional you can have contemporary
additions which actually show the
difference in ages as a property has
developed through the years the concerns
that the conservation officer has in
terms of the extension is his actual
positioning particularly on this gable
wall at the moment it has a type of an
l-shape approach with the separate coach
house this extension by means of the
projection is going to erode that in the
conservation officers of you
to an unacceptable degree so the
conservation officer has concluded that
there is a less than substantial harm
not substantial but less than
substantial hole and there has been no
public benefits that have been
identified to override that concern
thank you as in the previous application
where the conservation officer said that
it was the high end of lesson
substantial harm do we happen to know
where it's listed as less than
substantial in discussions with the
conservation officer yesterday she
didn't say it was the high end but it's
higher than moderate okay thank you any
other technical questions okay debate
Council Jones examples of this committee
and Planning Office approving of a kind
of modern juxtaposition so hoto divan is
an example that this committee approved
which was a way of taking that listed
building you've got a modern brick
extension and then there's a glazed a
modern glazed section to link the two
and that was felt to be a way of
creating a delineation so that you
weren't merging them so there's no
objection in principle and our
conservation officers or officer doesn't
have an objection to that in principle
you know my the difficulty is is that at
the moment there is a sort of I mean
fashion sounds a derogatory word but
essentially that's what it is there is a
fashion for saying well pastiche isn't
acceptable where you can't tell the
difference where you can't tell the
difference between the original building
and the new building that's not
desirable so let's put something modern
on but actually if we do look at it from
another perspective if you were to ask a
passerby about the more modern in quotes
20th century extensions to this property
I'm not talking about the conservatory
seventies I'm talk about the older ones
that were described as being sort of
a pastiche the reality is a layperson
would look at us and say well it's in
keeping and it does actually respect the
design so I know that modern
architecture doesn't like pastiche but
actually often it it does have its place
and actually I don't think this is a bad
example of where you've had sequential
alteration that's been in keeping and
and I do think there's something in the
common comment that it's not just it's
not the fact of a modern extension it's
the fact that we've got quite intricate
Tudor gothic detailing and then you add
something which is a really functional
look about it and I think it's the
contrast of those so it's not it's not
the contrast of new and old it's the
fact of you know they're quite stark and
I understand what councilor Ralph says
you know about lack of objection from
Alvis and so on so forth but in my mind
that has very limited weight because I
do think as a committee we've got to
look broader than that this isn't about
what you know whether whether the the
relevant personnel at the time happen to
like it or not I think I think again I'd
go back to what we said on the other one
I think we do have to be quite careful
you know a conservation officer is our
planning officers on this are they're
experts about it and they they
understand it and I think their
understanding of it frankly is probably
better than ours in terms of what is you
know what is a modification that's
acceptable and what isn't and we can see
here that there are extensive repairs it
says here extensive repairs to be
carried out to the building and the
conservation has raised no objection to
those repairs so there's a lot that the
conservation officer obviously hasn't
raised objection to for the two things
that she does say is she is concerned
about the removal of a wall at the first
floor level and she is concerned about
this extension and I don't see anything
in the reasoning in this report that
makes me say you know it doesn't make
sense to me so I personally would
caution the committee against taking its
own subjective view about whether or not
they quite like this because quite
frankly you're never going to know
whether you like it until it's built
anyway and I'd be more inclined to to
look at the reasoning that's
it's out in detail in the report and see
whether you actually think there's a
good reason why you disagree with that
and I don't see anything in there to
disagree with Thank You chairman this is
one of those ones where it's very finely
balanced and we're being absolutely
guided here by the conservation officer
I mean that that's that's really the
only reason and obviously there are
there are no objections and there is
positive support from both imeem one of
the reasons but for this is it would
facilitate repairs well quite frankly
you can do the repairs without making
the extension so so I think that's a bit
moot the removal of an internal wall
well it doesn't look to me to be too
substantial it's nothing that anybody
would see you know there are a lot of
this type of buildings about I mean it's
just making a building more functional I
don't see that as being a particularly
conservation issue it is a modest
extension but my only problem with it is
probably in the materials being used I'm
sort of coming around to the view that
sounds a bit old-fashioned but if it was
done in white stucco rather than this
what seems to be fairly modern material
I I really wouldn't have any problem
with this now you look at the benefits
the benefits are you getting rid of a
terrible limb gazebo thing and you're
making the house more functional I mean
in terms of policy cs9 my argument that
it probably would improve the quality of
the public realm but any subjective and
as councillor Charles said I'm no expert
on this type of thing cs20 there's
another thing well I think actually in
terms of its scale as a development I
can't see it being anything but not I'm
50/50 on this chairman I think it does
and it says in the port do less than
substan
for harm and perhaps that's the way we
should be going counsel bones well sort
of the same opinion is the last Baker
really it isn't very big it is making
the place considerably better to live in
which is an important factor where the
materials are right or not I don't know
but there the conservation architect
here
he's obviously concerned and we can see
the reasons but I don't think that in my
eyes they're strong enough for you know
as I say 5050 I would be happy to go
either way thank you
I must have it promote perspective I
think it's quite an exciting respiration
and I think they're going to do a
fantastic job by the sounds of things
and that's quite a quite an interesting
thing as well taking that challenge on
them well I to a certain extent it's
quite interesting the subjective element
of this is I'm not actually that that
against it although I would rather see
some better materials as water so
however we have a dilemma here as a
committee because what will fit into
that space that the conservation officer
would accept or is it never going to be
developed and that's the concern because
we have to consider how modern old
buildings are brought into the modern
age and we see this all the time through
this committee so I have got real
concerns that whatever is proposed will
not be suitable and that concerns me
because that means that the
functionality of this house and I call
it a house not a cottage I think it is
house really and truthfully you gotta
consider how you could build something
that will extend the very small kitchen
functional for the for modern age etc
but still appeals to the conservation
officer and I think Nagada there so like
everyone so far I think
the other thing I do have to say members
is again that there is considered to be
lessen substantial harm and we have been
to look at if there are any public
benefits to outweigh that harm and so if
that's an opinion for this committee
then that has to be considered I just
wanted to respond to some of the points
made by both council launcher and new
chair and firstly to say we good to see
interesting to know what the
conservation would officer would accept
and I would be interested to see
actually if we if we had an extension
that actually did look more like the
building that is already there in other
words is in keeping and I know that's
always derogatorily referred to as
pastiche but actually as I say another
word for that is in keeping you know
actually because I don't think the
concern is that there is any extension
at all and the scale I think committee
seems to be if the view is appropriate
but it's just about the incongruity of
the two I think I think what needs to be
borne in mind is that our officers don't
always agree with the conservation
officer so we've seen on some of our
other applications tonight you know
planning officers as specifically said
we listen to what the conservation
officer says but actually at our
planning balance for tomorrow so we
don't quite agree
well actually we hear we have officers
who are agreeing with the conservation
officers opinion and I think that should
contribute to the weight in terms of the
issue of less than substantial harm it's
really misleading that phrase we always
have this but substantial harm is we're
basically demolishing hope it's you know
you're never gonna I mean this committee
is barely ever going to see a
recommendation is substantial so less
than substantial for all intents and
purposes means harmful you know so it
the point is this is harmful in the view
of both the planning officers and the
conservation officers so on that basis I
completely agree with the chair that
they would need to be some public
benefit and that isn't identified so in
my view all of those things do tip the
balance and as I say I would propose
refusal because I do feel that there's
nothing in what is well reason
to suggest that actually we we ought to
be saying no we really disagree thank
you any other debate all I do have a
proposer do I have a seconder on this
it's a tricky one and I think that all
of us are considering the option I will
have to go with the officer on this one
because I can't see the public benefits
now if someone can come to me with with
that then I will say fine but I can't
see coming forward so I just I can't go
against the officer and the conservation
officers findings on this one so I'm I
will second counselor Charles's proposal
this is a finely balanced one members
but I'm going to put it to the vote the
vote before you are on are taken against
separately the vote before you is 18
staff double-o 436 flashes for all those
in favor to refuse plain commission
against that fails so you're proposing
to chair just to say we do need members
if they're going that way to identify
the public balance the public benefits
which outweigh the less than substantial
harm to the listed building well can we
just start off with policy then I think
that it doesn't go against policy cs9 I
mean it does improve the quality of the
public realm it takes down an ugly
extension and it allows to this building
to be put into modern use and I believe
cs20 it Oh give me the cause of thiers
20 because it is an appropriate scale
extension to this existing building
Chapman on the latter point that's a
private benefit it's not a public
benefit let's see I mean it has to be
the correct reasons obviously there's
judicial reviews so it has to be
correctly militate what are the public
benefits that justify going against the
lesser substantial harm and at the
moment with the greatest respect I
haven't got any overriding public
benefits I also am struggling you're
obviously this committee is minded to
approve this and I think perhaps the
office is because it is a technical
issue could go to guidance on on what
reasons we have for approval because at
the moment we have that it seems to
point to two CS policies but that
doesn't seem to be enough in the eyes of
the officer I can't see the point of the
improvement in the public realm being
having that much weight in this
particular instance
guide but you have obviously issues of
local construction jobs which is again
I'm not necessary right along from an
officer perspective maybe something as
members that you would like to consider
as well I think we have to also bear in
mind we all agreed it's finely balanced
so these are finely balanced arguments
in favor as much they find out they
weren't finely balanced ones against so
we're not gonna have something
everyone's gonna go WOW but I think it
is benefits the building it creates jobs
local immunity check I think those
officers we've got the gist if I can
leave us with that we've made some notes
on that one so we get the general I was
just saying on the benefits the listed
building you're accepting harm to the
listed building just so to say that it
benefits the listed building this
doesn't stack up but the benefits for
the people in the kitchen and the
improvements of the house but outweighs
as far as I can see the concern in
conservation architect as which is
minimal we're here as committee to look
at things and to go through things and
discuss things this is where were in a
situation where it's finely balanced and
we go in the other way I'm sorry but no
we're not here as a committee to go oh
what do we think of this application do
we like it or not yes or no balance
we'll just weigh up something that's not
our function is function is to make
decisions in accordance with the rules
and the guidance the rule and the
guidance is if there is an identified
harm which there clearly is you must
have very clear public benefits to our
ways it's not just a question of we're
here to make a decision on which one we
prefer and do what are the benefits and
you know in the question of listed
buildings there's very clear guidance
and rules as to how we should operate
I'm you're with the greatest respect
there the full committee members who are
wanting and I understand why that you
why you want it and you've explained the
reasons but you're straining what you're
doing is you're straining to do what you
want and make the rules fit what you
want and I don't think it don't think it
stacks up and I for my perspective also
and I don't want a decision being made
on such a tenuous ground that will come
back and bite us on the future
education is also category seek
clarification then from the legal
officer so you mentioned if I was saying
it benefits this a building why do we
have to accept there is harm to a listed
building why don't we just say we don't
accept this confidence of building it is
purely a benefit to a listed building
that's fine if it's your judgment that
there is no harm but from what I've
heard so far it there seems to be an
acceptance that there is less than the
substantial harm I suppose by the fact I
believe there is a benefit to it by
default I'm saying there was no harm to
this mister building so my position
would be there is a benefit to this
listed building and that is the public
interest as to why chair I request that
we put it to the vote on that basis the
second point means I've got a close-up
and the second is a correct answer for G
those seconding can't afford to get a
second right let's just run through the
general what the committee are saying is
they read the officer report they
believe with the subjective nature of
things yes they're mindful of what
policy cs8 says the mindful of what the
NPP G says in terms of whether there is
less than substantial harm or no harm
whilst noting what the conservation
officers recommendation is committee
members believe that there is no harm
being caused in terms of cs8 and in
terms of NPP F and therefore because
there's no harm there's no need to find
any public benefits that also I think as
Lawton has made mention of CS 9 and I
think you mentioned says 20 so I think I
think in a nutshell chair if the members
can make it perfectly clear but they're
saying they believe there is no harm
then as officers
we'd be happy with that well I think
just to clear one cs9 in our opinion I
believe we are saying that it does
improve the quality of the public realm
and cs20 that the actual scale of the
alteration is perfectly acceptable in
line with cs20 the only question I just
want to ask is are there any
implications if this committee says that
this in the committee's definition they
don't think these words represent any
harm at all does that have any future
implications on any other application
Chairman each application is considered
in China on its own merits now in this
particular instance you're looking at
your removing and inappropriate
conservatory your move removing what you
believe to be inappropriate later 20th
century editions if I can put it like
that another application will come in
which will you'll still have to consider
cs8 you'll still have to consider the
end PPF but it will be a different
proposal on a different site and
therefore you will be considering that
as I've said inside on its own merits
thank you I have a proposal cancellation
sorry jack and I just just add in in
terms of conditions is the proposer
happen happy for those to be delegated
to offices and in consultation with the
Chairman okay based on this just been
reading through the report some
potential conditions that could go on
would be time limits drawing numbers
making good material samples scheduling
works
development in a course with the
landscaping I that relates to the
policed hedging also notes with regards
to ecological note in an MPP F paragraph
186 note I would be mindful that
potentially would like to yeah we'd like
to run that construction
management plan but I would like to run
that by the conservation officer on the
basis of there may be something specific
that I that I have not picked up on
thank you right in that case then based
on what we've just discussed with as
those recommendations and conditions
castle Lawton in this proposed
counterbalance the sake did members the
vote before you is to grant a planning
permission and we're going to go through
both individually for 18 staff double O
4 3 6 / fault all those in favor against
and for 18 start double O 4 3 7 SOT lbc
all those in favor to grant permission
and against this committee therefore
resource to grant plan commission for 18
start double O 4 3 6 / 4 and 18 start
double O 4 3 subs on LBC thank you very
much indeed the last item on the agenda
counts of Audrey will be taking over
so last night's on the agenda actually
can't Cara fie one thing my
understanding is that if members have an
application are they meant to leave the
room as opposed to sit in it I think
mark you're you're obliged to sit
outside I'm afraid personal experience
yeah so we're here the reason this
application is before this committee is
because it's it's district councillors
application 1701 for five three full
construction of a rear side open brand
are joined to the northwest of the
dwelling and construction of a rear side
partially enclosed veranda joined to the
southeast of the dwelling elect also
planning officer to run to it for us
Anke chair by apologies for moving away
from you it's better to present here and
I said we've left the most controversial
application till West and I can I thank
you chair for clarifying that this
application is only before you members
because of the it's a counselor
application it is not controversial no
objections have been received the
scientists of the south of old Esther
Alsace there you can see the black dots
where the site is and the application
site is edged by the redlining what has
been proposed to to miranda's in this
location where the little hand is and
also in that location so it's on the
rear elevation and what's being proposed
at the rear of an existing Garden Room
is an open veranda and to the rear of
the utility a partially enclosed veranda
so this was the Garden Room and there's
a sort of a glass lantern above the
existing Garden Room which if I'll make
reference to when you look at
photographs but this is the the open
fronted veranda it is going to be
resting on an existing dwarf wall which
you'll see on photographs and this is
the partially enclosed random
projecting from the utility room again
on a existing dwarf wall so there was
the Lancer I mentioned this is the
Garden Room you don't have the veranda
projecting up to this dwarf wall here
and that was the utility room with the
partially enclosed rounder projecting to
that dwarf wall I hope you don't see the
cursor moving there it's going to extend
outwards from mrs. sorry this is the one
by the garden room with the one with the
lantern it's projecting out from the
wall by four point three meters and it's
going to be some five point seven meters
in length you can see the the wall here
what is extending beyond the wall is the
roof overhang and if you look at the
sectional drawing the one on the left
you can see the posts will be resting on
that existing dwarf wall and there is
the roof overhang it's a very shallow
mono pitched roof just below the parapet
of the existing garden room you can see
better detail of the elevational
appearance on the right and so again
that is where it is going in this
particular location top of it just below
the parapet the other veranda the
partially enclosed one from the utility
room is some 3.5 meters and it's going
to be about four point nine meters in
length again you can see the existing
wall it's going to be resting on the
existing world and it is partially
enclosed it doesn't go the whole length
of the utility room that's where it will
be going to so we go into about you can
see where the cursor is there and there
was a dwarf wall where the cursor was
shown from public vantage points from
the road there's the there's that
mountain top you saw it's on the other
side of that so it's gonna be minimal if
any impact from this viewpoint and on
this elevation one of the rounders down
there and the other here again minimal
if any public view
public views at all so chair the
recommendation is one of approval has
put the officer report thank you very
much
no one's ability to speak and the ward
members not tear-soaked I suggest we
just go straight to technical questions
the planning officer from the committee
so any anyone have technical questions
okay apart from a comment about his
grass is very messy can I suggest we go
straight - straight to debate Flores
Flores - councilman's propose what
forward okay so on the basis that is
proposed by Council of arms seconded by
Councillor awesome the recommendation is
to grant planning permission subject to
a very short list of conditions three
years in accordance with plans materials
and accordance with those stated on
plans and application detailed wording
delegated offices or away from you sorry
about that so that we proved about all
those in favor against passed
unanimously so I'm gonna do this Vick I
want to hit the gavel so urgent business
only urgent business in that case the
meeting is closed